jeff lagarius a mathematician i admire a
lot thinks it's one of the hardest
problems around herdish actually said
this is a problem for which mathematics
is perhaps not ready turns out all this
fuss is about a problem that any fourth
grader can understand to show you how
this all works i'm going to give you an
example brady choose a number between 1
and 10. i shall go for 7. all right
let's start with 7. now i'm going to
apply two rules depending on what number
i get to i'm going to do this in
succession and if n is even then i'm
going to take n and divide it by 2. if n
is odd then i'm going to take n can't
divide it by 2 and get a whole number so
i'm going to take n and multiply it by 3
and add 1. those are my rules and i'm
interested in what happens to n does it
grow to infinity does it get small let's
see what happens with 7. 7 seems to be
an odd number so i multiply by 3 and add
1. 3 times 7 is 21. check me on this and
add 1 is 22 i go to 22. 22 is certainly
even so i'll divide by 2 and get 11. 11
is odd so i multiply by 3 getting 33 and
add 1 get 34. 34 is even i divide by 2
and i get 17. so so far it's sort of
going up and down but 34 was the biggest
yet so maybe it's headed off to infinity
after all
17. so 17 is odd i multiply by three
three times ten is thirty three times
seven is twenty-one fifty-one plus one
is fifty-two even
divide by
two and get twenty-six still even divide
by two again get thirteen now it's odd
multiply by three and add one forty
forty is even
i divide i get twenty i divide again i
get ten
i divide again i get five boy we fell
down a long way maybe we're heading for
a small number after all multiply by 3
and add 1 i get 16.
whoa 16 very even number
i get
and i get 1. if i do it again something
interesting happens i go
3 times 1 plus 1 is 4 whoops i'm back to
4 but now i'm just going to cycle
forever
going through 1 over and over again so i
got to 1 7 got to 1. now people have
tried lots of numbers beginning this way
and so far
all of them have gone to one they've
tried roughly two to the sixtieth
numbers that's almost 10 to the 20th so
the famous colots conjecture says that
every number every whole number will
eventually get to one and a huge amount
of work has been done on this problem by
combinatorialists by number theorists
this is the problem
that maybe mathematics is not ready for
but that any fourth fourth grader could
play with and try right try some numbers
first of all we'd like to understand
what's happening in such a way that we
can say for certainty that every number
all the numbers we haven't ever tried
will get to one you could just try this
on your computer it's a good test for
your personal computer too how fast a
program can you make here's a little
hint
every time i take an odd number and
multiply by three and add one i get an
even number so why not
take two steps at once
to
three n plus one over two
combine those two steps when i get an
odd number that speeds things up a bit
and there are other tricks like that so
people make graphs like this
and they're called trees right they so
far all the numbers
go down to one but we might start with
another number if we started with 5 we
already see what the answer would be any
number that appears here we already know
the answer we don't have to do it again
what's the first number that doesn't
appear here
i think it's 6. should we try 6 let's do
it let's do it okay six and six goes
well it's even it goes to three three
goes to ten have we got ten whoops
there's ten so i should just draw that
three going down to ten instead and now
i know i'm beginning to build up my tree
i've tried now all the numbers up
through
seven
uh
eight i've got
nine i thought i had somewhere
didn't i have a nine i can't say enough
no i don't see nine let's try nine
so nine okay
odd number three times nine plus one
twenty-eight twenty-eight
fourteen
whoops seven
where's my seven there it is
it goes to 7. so i can begin doing this
and build up my tree i don't have to go
all the way each time i know what's
going to happen after i get to 7. if you
look at the cover of this book that i
showed you first
that's a tree of just this kind but
people have built up huge trees of this
kind and there's a wonderful article on
wikipedia that you can look at which
shows some of the the pictures of this
there does seem to be a very striking
feature of it and this is this line down
the middle here that's right this is
like the third rail once you touch that
line you fall right away to one
by the way there's another name for the
this problem which is the hailstone
problem and the reason is as you
probably know when hailstones form in
the clouds the way they form the way
they get bigger is that they start low
and they get blown up by the winds and
they get some ice on them and they fall
down a bit
and then they go up and down they go up
and down many times and finally they
fall to earth they never get to earth of
course they're not hailstones and it's
just like numbers here they go seemingly
randomly up and down and up and down and
then eventually they seem to fall to one
to the ground what kind of things have
people done with this funny funny
problem
well they've compiled for instance
records i i got a long string with seven
what's the next number after seven which
gives a longer string well it's not
eight eight is down here
we found it already it's nine nine only
goes through 7.
what's the next number after that well
you can look on the online encyclopedia
of integer sequences that great resource
and you'll find a table
of the record-holding numbers you'll
also find a table of the numbers that
hold the record for the longest time to
get to one let's get a couple of
examples here there's some wonderful
ones for instance the longest the one
the record holder for the number is
under 100 million people people know all
these things
is
63 million 728
and that takes 949 steps to get to one i
bet the person who
found it thought maybe he was on onto
something maybe he finally had a counter
example but no there are records and
records and records and people have
tabulated this looking for patterns that
might help them understand what's really
going on
so the randomness of this is what seems
to make it hard the fact that we don't
see a pattern
and that
no matter how hard you look the patterns
you see tend to be illusory somehow they
will they melt away when you look
further or you don't understand them
like the pattern of always going to one
that one holds sure but
but we don't understand why it's there
if you'd like to see even more of this
interview about the collets conjecture
i've posted it at number file two why
three n plus one why not three n minus
one
brady let's try a three n minus one in
case you don't know professor eisenberg
is the director at msri which is a huge
supporter of numberphile
you can see more videos with professor
eisenbud or other videos filmed at msri
by clicking the links on the screen or
in the video description i'm going to
draw that line
i'm going to draw this line